[Musique]
petit fruit d'euros fruit on les déguste
de toutes sortes de façons il se mange
très bien en salade
alors ajoutons l'est dans nos vies
direct quand la joute des fruits à la
vinaigrette et qu'on ajoute ensuite sur
20 km et 109 émargé faisait légumes plus
des fruits puis c'est ça qu'on veut est
prévue outre quand on ajoute les fruits
anti-omc bénéficient toutes les
vitamines tous les minéraux que dans les
fruits mais aussi toutes les fibres les
fibres alimentaires dont ceux-ci
excellent point de vue digestion danse
et on a tendance à manger trop gras trop
sucré trop salé
donc quand je t'ai de la saveur à nos
salaires dans nos aliments des sans
ajouter de ces nutriments là
effectivement quand on ajoute une purée
de fruits ça permet de diminuer un peu
la qualité gras qu'on va utiliser donc
et espère la base d'une vinaigrette
c'est très simple en corps gras est un
ingrédient à 6,20 grave est indifférent
de savoir encore un peu coupé gras
complètement même si on peut diminuer
grâce à la purée de fruits marie-eve
propose trois recettes simples de
vinaigrette aux fruits tout d'abord à
l'avocat et fine scène
on commence avec la chaire de deux
avocats du yogourt grec nature une
gousse d'ail un peu d'eau puis de
l'aneth du persil et de la menthe
fraîche
dès 6 heures je vais pas les lâcher par
contre je suis attirée les tic sont un
peu plus coriace
donc j'ai mis la menthe de la nerthe si
vous êtes le père si on passe le tout au
mélangeur et on ajoute de l'eau besoin
afin d'obtenir la texture désirée
un autre bel exemple et la vinaigrette à
la mangue et pis c'est une tasse de
cubes de mangue le zeste et le jus d'une
lime de l'huile d'olive écrit avec un
petit peu de piquant à l'intérieur pour
relever de tous à peu près 5000
ça me donne d'ailleurs plus liquides
ouais je peux plus liquide que c'est
l'avocat puisse en velin texto pure et
pinceaux prennent prononcer les mots
quand j'ai finalement une vinaigrette ou
bleuets avec du vinaigre balsamique du
jus de citron de l'huile d'olive et du
basilic est discret on ajoute les sirops
d'érable à ces années
[Musique]
pour la vinaigrette aux bleuets par
exemple ça pourrait être une salle avec
qui le fromage de chèvre des betteraves
de pacanes caramélise écrire pour aller
rechercher le côté un peu sucré salé
pour la vinaigrette à la mangue
j'irai avec quelque chose de plus de
plus doux plus léger par exemple sa
pratique crevettes avec concombres comme
ça ça ferait vraiment ressortir et la
saveur de la mangue puis l'année groupe
à l'avocat ça pourrait par exemple une
salade style l'ex cannes avec des
tomates des maillets idéal tournoi un
petit peu de fromage ce serait bien
quant à la maison sont utilisés - des
gressins il y aura pendant plus d'agents
de conservation
bon d'un point de vue nutritionnel si
toujours mieux faire si ce n'est
attendre c'est vraiment cru à ses fans
parce que ça pourrait aussi servir de
rampe
oui on prêt à sauver sa trempe et d'un
des légumes avec des crudités en entrée
ça serait super man
ça c'est mangue avec ces nations oui
c'est très bon avec la petite finale un
pic à lé parquet ne les tue tout simple
mais c'est fou si elles se passent un
bouche à benjamin petit côté assène la
cité mme avec le sucre et des fruits
vous savez le bel qu'est ce qu'on veut
il n'y a pas de règle vraiment c'est d'y
aller avec nos goûts à nous on peut
l'aimer plus acide en feu les plus
sucrés s'est jamais caché si j'avais on
trouve que c'est trop sur par exemple
trop acide
on peut ajouter un plus d'ingrédients
sucre et on peut rajouter plus deviner
qui conseille vraiment d'essayer de
jouer avec les aliments
dans ce cas là on peut jouer avec la
nourriture oui ronaldo avis c'est bien
le faire
[Musique]